voltar a assistir a isto funciona no
bairro outro funciona muito bem pessoas
garantiram que já está ok
ai eu chamo os selos da fonseca tem 85
anos e certamente já tô só entrou na
área tão distante 105 anos quer que este
bebida que vai fazer é enorme nenhuma
quando fizeram o convite e winter games
alimentos e devia vir aqui mas o próprio
cardápio do telex tirou algumas dúvidas
popular disse claramente que os 35 anos
já deu faço suficiente para dar três
voltas 13 voltas o mundo a pé
juntei duas na minha vida profissional a
volta às fitas volta do avião num fraco
durante estilo tom o tempo não tenha
nada a dizer menina meditação aquela
juventude está a frenética que alguém
via como é que a vida vai continuar e
que vai e que eu julgo voar um sentido
um balanço vemos ser os cuidados que
devemos ter na vida em que temos que ter
é a anchieta exatamente quando os
canhões nacional para fora um tempo
difícil negro tempos em que tudo foi um
tempo em campo foi rolando naturalmente
no vitor mas fui aprendendo a se ver
toda aquela sozinha volta da minha casa
o miro bbc
ouviram o país ficaram atrás o avanço
a tropa o distribuirá propaganda a ufra
tudo isso marcou fundamento e toxina no
ambiente e arquiteto
inquieto sendo nenhuma e acima tudo no
brinquedo no um casamento é ver um
sentido da responsabilidade da vida e
tantas possibilidades na vida foi
provocada por aquela é a idéia do que eu
não suportaria mais era não sofrer mais
em grandes com isso outros outros e não
e nunca em entrevista à possibilidade
sequer de poder é a minha liberdade
quando na pacha já feita
eu aprendi nesse palco em todos os
palcos com disputava contra hoje mas a
lista não se acha que o neto brandão
o flamengo sabe que fundos os últimas
mensagens de seus tempos nas prévias
antes das listas para mim que quer ficar
e é isso que vem sendo para perceber o
que é que aquilo que não queremos guerra
e retornou com todos nossos ser o que
sabia das coisas que eu sabia que não
podia ser professor é professor entendia
que espera profissão para o homem nasceu
com problemas causados pela miséria
conclusão que pagava por outro lado
nenhuma informação de que se aqui de
novo na profissão para o homem então a
discutir outra qualquer uma vez que
também não tinha uma presença muito
especial quero ouvir os prós e contras
ouvindo opiniões valem ache eu inclusive
por é a nature
o curso de engenharia mecânica e pensar
que está muito com isso pois na frente
nós iremos ver o que é que lá e isso
fala pela nova placa mãe eu e também
nesta fase
aprendi uma coisa muito significativa
para o que aprender a aprender e depois
praticar e que os pais não podem nem
devem
glória o professor filhos mas também
acompanhar também os meus companheiros
nós aconselhamos nunca devem sobrepor à
sua volta lá advogado para trás da
profissão que exercem sobre xuxa foi um
brincadeira com uma outra falta e e e
temos o exame em outro país
à porta fechada e com a porta para ver
se estava fundamental e no final
atualmente a nota mais do que aquela
é porque ele é partir daí é a partir daí
foi uma boa passagem amanhã 10 à minha
frente
todos os cursos se importavam se eu
estava calmo e lutámos muito mais
estava calmo antes do antes do exame
propriamente saber se eu sabia a nossa
linha da frente
ele foi pouco a pouco mais do que um
banho de sangue são paulo a maior porque
eu não sinto nem um mandamento nem
profissionalmente ou condições são tal
como eu vai ser um em todo o respeito e
portanto eu não vou pra essa profissão
ela pra falar estava em um curso que
parece é e eu em todo o mundo o mundo
aprendia muito forte aqui temos de ser
os companheiros que iria mudar o óleo ou
para fazer e quando resolve se visitas à
vida civil
o certo é o certo é
é que não sentia completamente o senhor
me aí sim
assim estava a meio de um super super as
fotos quanto mais forte e melhor para
mim eu já sabia perfeitamente conduzir o
quarto cria com 11
nós temos o é assim sempre que o
importante é o mais importante de tudo é
libertar nos dela sempre que possível
se quisermos ter valor e e não e aí o
êxito
a este valor não andam sempre juntos a
êxito você apanha porque está no sítio
certo o valor esse acontecido ao longo
do tempo ao longo de uma vida sem dúvida
nenhuma
foram 22 anos espera que aparecesse